こんにちははじめ社長です相次いで皆さん今日ですね私は肇社長のクッキングコーナー
でございますはい皆発注
あ
まず吐きそうですねよくね知恵手出しを食べる米メジャーな中寿司といったらコレです
ね寝る寝る寝るとかメジャーじゃないですよね
こういうチーク場所ですね本体お店にある分全種類買ってきました
いきわけですねはいこちらですねハ病んでる2つなんじゃ
こちらのチーク箇所ですねはい全書に買ってきたわけなんで入ると市議などチークス
全種に混ぜるとアロイ味になるかっていうのを果たして料理金にいいかとしてですね
入りたくなったわけなんですよアテネで今日あの
ちーフラッシュ早く混ぜて早んね味なんかかっていうねはい実験的にねやっていいか
問うわけないよあれははいいきましょうはいもう一杯まずはどんな地域頭が見ていき
ましょう
ます
海が一番の宮見える濡れてる
ran
goo
あれでこちらのというこちらの長車両ですね
全部まとめて一つの音チーク菓子を作ろうと思いますではいきましょうとか作る順番度
かんだよな
油断はできない上デーに感謝そのまま食べて阿呆もっとリーフ会社をつかないことに
なってきたぞ
それからチーフがして蜜いるんだってめんどくさいでコーナーでいいでしょとになると
かわかんになっている
ぶりに挟んいるし朝目が入りません強く頭のでは行こう
これハサミ入らないんだ
なんか吐く吐く吐く吐くスペースなぜなら黒いよ
大丈夫かなでもなくカラーフィルターはカラーくれ違ってきました嬉しい子ってことか
何か出来そうな気がした
ただのこちらはわかりでも何が何だ効果を持っていることもわかりやすいこれ確実に
固まっても確実に肩までより確実な悪行に近づくかなりクオリティの高いここに行っ
ちゃったよりすごいぞコレなにようになるから何コレなにいやに誰かで大きく違って
待ってれば
壊れなんだろう知らなかったので軽い気持ちでやったらまあまあビッグな僕のせいじゃ
ないかねえ
これ現実よなー子ども達見てるからどんな可愛いね動物とか人間には音止めたいそんで
るってわけよ人の心にへばりつくはけど振っても落ちないもん
あってずっと食べてみようと思いますいただきます
いろーんなしたいことが混じってよね組にしたいけどちょっと
そうだっぽいやつもしれないけどガメポしたいなみたいな紅と伴いな美味しい
まあ美味しいザフェイス今回ですね混ぜるとねこうなるということを皆さんにお知らせ
従ってあげてくださいますはい
2位はじめスポーツプーッ管穿孔
しています